unterwegs auf der A7 bereits am Morgen
ist Alex kutscheroff im
niedersächsischen Stade gestartet soll
einen Flugzeugflügel nach Frankfurt Hahn
bringen dem gebürtigen Kasachen macht
das stundenlange fahren wenig aus das
Problem die Pausen
Pause sollen wir machen oder müssen wir
machen
mindestens nach viereinhalb Stunden die
gesetzlich vorgeschriebenen Pausen
machen gern nur wo Stellplätze sind
Mangelware am Tag geht das ja aber so
nach 17 18 Uhr das ist schlimm schon mit
körperparkplätze entlang der deutschen
Autobahnen fehlen noch Schätzungen
mindestens 20.000 Stellplätze und das
bei weiter wachsenden Güterverkehr die
Situation auf den vorhandenen Anlagen so
eine Studie ist ADAC teils chaotisch die
Hälfte der Anlagen da war so dass in den
sensiblen ein und Ausfahrt reichen also
sogar auf dem Standstreifen LKW standen
und 90% der Anlagen waren sogar wo die
LKW im absoluten Halteverbot standen
beispielsweise oder eben auch nicht für
Sie zugewiesenen Plätzen
LKW die bis auf die Autobahn stehen weil
sie keinen anderen Platz finden die
Folgen fatal immer wieder kommt es zu
schweren Unfällen mit Toten und
Verletzten wenn andere Fahrer die teils
unbeleuchteten Lastwagen in den
Zufahrten zur Raststätte übersehen
auch ihr Job nicht ungefährlich
wenn man auf dem Parkplatz fährt oder so
gibt es schon öfter mal so einen kleinen
schreckenmoment das ist auf einmal schon
der LKW steht Hannes Dressler und Jannik
Münzel auf Kontrollfahrt den beiden
Beamten von der Autobahnpolizei
Hildesheim bietet sich jede Nacht
dasselbe Bild
jetzt sieht man hier rechts LKW schon
mal spätesten ja alles keine LKW
Parkplätze die parken ja schon außerhalb
der LKW Parkbuchten
aber so sieht das also mindestens so
sieht das halt immer aus auch abends
schon
auf der folgenden Raststätte kommen die
Polizisten nicht weiter ja der sucht
sich jetzt
irgendwo eine Parklücke
ein LKW versucht irgendwie in die letzte
freie für ihn aber eigentlich zu kleine
Parklücke zu kommen blockiert so
minutenlang die Durchfahrt
das Problem der will halt Einparken
zwischen den beiden LKW
weil er kein anderen Parkplatz gefunden
hat mehr und so fängt das dann langsam
an hier alles
ja sehr eng zu werden so dass irgendwann
halt auch kein LKW mehr durchkommt jetzt
zweiter Weg Fersengeld geben bevor er
ein Bußgeld riskiert Falschparken in
Italien oder Österreich wird das mit
1000 € geahndet in Deutschland kostet es
nur 35 € eine lenkzeitüberschreitung ist
im Zweifel teurer aber höhere Bußgelder
wissen auch die Polizisten lösen das
Problem der fehlenden Plätze nicht am
nächsten Parkplatz treffen die beiden
wieder auf den LKW von vorhin und wieder
steht der alles andere als richtig
ihr seid zum Beispiel das Problem das
ist
Behindertenparkplatz der hier zugeparkt
wurden von ihm und das ist auch zufällig
der LKW von eben
und sprechen
Sie parken raten Parkplatz zu für
Behinderte der muss immer frei bleiben
das heißt hier
nein nee so leider so leider nicht
gucken ja leider schon ja sechs
Kilometer kommt der nächste
bahnplatzmeister
dass die Situation der Brummifahrer
schwierig ist dafür haben die Polizisten
Verständnis Bußgelder Brummen sie kaum
jemand im auf den Beamten gibt es
weniger um Strafe viel mehr um Gefahren
Abwehr auf zum nächsten Parkplatz
hier der klassische Fall ein LKW in der
Auffahrt und beleuchtet kaum zu erkennen
der Fahrer schon im Tiefschlaf muss
geweckt werden
hallo Polizei du kannst dir nicht so
stehen bleiben das geht nicht
du musst du musst weiterfahren
ist zu gefährlich mit der mit der
Abfahrt das Risiko hier enorm wenn hier
ein Unfall passiert ist der Führerschein
weg
der Körperverletzung oder verlässlicher
Tötung wir können ihn nur sagen fahr
bitte weiter such dir einen anderen
Parkplatz du stehst hier viel zu
gefährlich und es ist jede Nacht immer
das gleiche wer jede Nacht schicken wir
die LKW-Fahrer hier weg aber es ja es
ändert sich jetzt erstmal auf Zeit
nichts sie wissen genau der eine fährt
weg der nächste stellt sich bald wieder
hin verzweifelte Lkw-Fahrer hilflose
Polizisten und für die Speditionen ist
es ein teures Ärgernis weil die Fahrer
Zeit und Sprit vergeuden einige
Unternehmen entlang der Autobahn öffnen
bereits ihr Gelände und ihre
Sanitäranlagen zumindest für Fahrer
befreundete Unternehmen sicher ist
sicher die dispozentrale dieser
Spedition modern voll vernetzt die haben
sie jeden ihre LKW genau im Blick was
aber ein intelligentes Leitsystem an den
Autobahnen angeht Deutschland
hoffnungslos hinterher ist digitales
Entwicklungsland
wir haben für unsere Fahrzeuge ein
durchgängiges tracking system wissen
also wo sie sind und haben Verbindung zu
dem Fahrzeug wenn es in Deutschland ein
intelligentes Leitsystem für Parkplätze
geben würde könnten die Fahrer
einerseits selbstständig sich
orientieren oder unsere Dispo könnte dem
Fahrer signalisieren der nächste
Parkplatz hat sonst irgendwie frei
Stellplätze egal ob nun digital oder
eine Anzeigetafel wie ein Innenstadt
Parkhaus in Deutschland gibt es nichts
dergleichen andere Länder sind da weiter
Alex kutscheros bleibt nur rausfahren
und nachgucken ob zufällig ein Platz
frei ist
ja das ist großer Glück bei ihren Pausen
sind die Fahrer meist Lärm und Abgasen
ausgesetzt nicht das einzige Risiko kein
Jahr alt ist sein LKW und schon mehrfach
aufgeschlitzt
und dann kann man gut sehen was ist da
drin da vorne auch eine an
Flugzeugflügeln haben die Diebe aber
wohl kein Interesse nach der Pause geht
es weiter bis er ausgeliefert hat und
Feierabend machen kann wird es wohl weit
nach Mitternacht sein und dann beginnt
es wieder das lange Suchen nach einem
Stellplatz für die Nacht